jeudi mal des fois à part leur mariage
au présent oui voilà
et du coup on se parlait et il me disait
je n'ai pas les gens sont agressifs les
gens ne disent pas bonjour au revoir
merci enfin je vais dire sans promo qui
sont tellement important c'est la base
de tout c'est la baisse puisqu'on a
inculqué nos enfances je veux dire c'est
tellement évident un regard de travers
ils en avaient assez et traîné la patte
et où on voulait plus et voulaient plus
et il lui tarde et dans un an
la retraite dans un an oui alors c'est
ça graissage que vous les avez rencontré
ce que vous avez des photos d'eux est ce
que vous savez de qui s'alimente pas je
ne savais absolument rien de et de toute
manière c'est moi je ne sais rien voilà
moi j'ai mon époux dans ma tête et je
l'espère l'inscription et je veux faire
confiance à la justice
voilà moi ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui
nous en voulaient à quelqu'un
aujourd'hui
alors j'en veux ouais oui un petit peu
oui j'en vos gouvernements charme au
gouvernement parce que j'ai eu des
soutiens c'est vrai j'ai eu de la vie on
a eu de la visite à la maison c'est vrai
de qui de du ministre de l'intérieur
d'accord on a eu et on a eu un malaise
chez paquet et assistance aux élites et
qui est maintenant rattaché à
l'intérieur voilà quelqu'un si aulas
était venu à la maison aussi donc
beaucoup de soutien beaucoup de paroles
beaucoup de réconfort je pensais je
d'ailleurs je leur ai dit j'ai bien
madame massiat pas j'ai dit je me
rappelle très bien aux obsèques
aidez nous voilà ce que j'ai comme ça
veut dire quoi aider ça veut dire et de
nous essayer de nous de nous faire
avancer
en prenant des nouvelles de temps en
temps en prenant on ne reste pas dans
l'oubli
voilà c'est ça ne pas rester dans
l'oubli parce que et en fait non cep
news
non c'est vrai que eric naulleau ou vous
acquiescié camp oui d'abord comme tous
mes collègues chez impressionné par
votre courage suis admiratif je sais pas
je pourrai le faire
moi je trouve que j'ai grandi à bayonne
même aujourd'hui naïvement je trouve
quelque chose qui colle pas entre
bayonne et la tragédie qui vous frappe
mais il faut revenir de cette naïveté
mais j'ai l'impression que le problème
est plus profond parce que en effet il
ya des mesures de sécurité mais il ya
quelque chose qui s'est déréglé dans la
société je pense pas que la sécurité
réglera pour qu'un incident aussi mineur
dégénère en drame et en tragédie que
vous allez vivre avec cette tragédie
toute votre vie il ya quelque chose qui
s'est déréglé dans les têtes et dans la
société
donc c'est pas seulement avec la
répression qu'on arrivera c'est qu'il
faut que les gens changent complètement
d'attitude et de mentalité ce sera très
long
donc commençons par faire un exemple
pour les meurtriers de votre mari de
votre de votre père mais je pense que ce
sera un travail de très longue haleine
les punir et ensuite porter ce message
que vous partez sur leur gâteau des rois
et marine étant donné qu'on est en
direct
j'ai un message de marlène schiappa qui
vous répond puisque vous nous aviez dit
un instant l'été venu avec donc au
ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin il faut savoir que
maintenant elle a été rattachée donc
jérôme marc darman à l'intérieur le
ministre de l'intérieur il vous a dit
quoi parce que je vais vous donner la
réponse de marine schiappa qui est
maintenant avec le ministre de
l'intérieur il vous a dit quoi quand il
est venu vous voir
ben nous a dit voilà comme logo et nous
soutenaient et comprenez notre tristesse
et tous voila mais enfin ça va pas
cesser c'est tout enfin je veux dire
il vous a parlé aussi de voilà de la
suite de voix la double enquête qu'il a
des pas du tout alors marlène schiappa
vous vous envoie un message je suis
toujours à la disposition de véronique
je lui ai dit je lui ai remis la
médaille d'acte de courage de dévouement
je défends aussi la mémoire de son mari
dès qu'il évoqué je pense souvent à l ac
3 formidable film on prend des nouvelles
par l'intermédiaire du préfet nous on
respecte aussi sa tranquillité la
séparation des pouvoirs car il ya une
enquête en cours
je lui ai dit que j'étais à sa
disposition et bien sûr je le suis
toujours
elle est très courageuse de venir rendre
hommage à son mari on sera toujours avec
n c'est une femme exceptionnelle et vous
avez bien fait de l'invité je reçois
j'entends d'accord voilà vous alors on
espère que voilà il faut des choses vont
bouger
ces jeux je reçois gens parce que